[Musique]
hé la nourriture de la fontaine a l'air vraiment bien trop
bien juste en essayant de me concentrer bien regarde
mon père ne me l'a pas dit juste avant de
mourir Oh moi là parce que ce n'était pas que
j'étais trop occupé à être obsédé par mes expériences sur les rayons gamma
J'ai raté la mort de mon propre père
parce que je me concentrais sur mon
destin mais je n'ai pas raté la
mort de mon père parce qu'il a été assassiné juste
devant moi par ma sœur dont je ne
savais même pas qu'elle existait parce qu'elle m'était tenue
secrète  toute ma vie a l'air
terrible, la comparaison n'a rien à
voir avec ce que vous traversez et ma
famille coûterait de se battre entre
nous alors que tout le monde en
souffre non j'étais des dieux et des runes et bien c'est ma
soeur bonjour comment savez-vous
Veta avant que tu ne puisses tuer ta sœur a
pensé comment humma
tu n'es pas le dieu martèle ici Dumbo
ne ressemble pas à un compliment c'est
totalement un compliment Dumbo Dumbo sonne
comme si tu m'appelais Dumbo encore
et encore
Dumbo à la maison dit une fois  plus je te dirai
un éléphant qui pense qu'elle peut voler
parce qu'il était une plume magique,
puis il perd une plume un jour et il se
rend compte qu'il n'a rien à voir avec le fait
qu'il vole
du tout.
tu vois des codes car les queues n'ont même rien dit
on est là ouais ouais débarrasse toi de
ça